oh hi
what is up um
let me pull up the chat
pop out chat there it is
okay
uh hello everyone i
wanted to watch today's state of play
that was at 2 p.m
pt uh today february 25th 2021 it is
kind of confusing to me that they don't
name these um
naturally i had work today at 2pm so i
can't watch these kinds of things
um certainly not now that i don't work
in games media we also used to do watch
throughs at fun house
so i can't do it anymore so i have to do
it after work and i basically just
finished work
came straight here we doing it um
i have no idea what is in this i
didn't even know it was happening until
the rest of the world did
i can confidently assume there is no god
of war
um i think it would be pretty weird if i
didn't know about that one
uh but i'm hoping there's death loop i
did avoid twitter so i don't have any
spoilers but
um a lot of you who've watched my stuff
before we'll know i'm extremely excited
about ratchet and clank
and death loop so hopefully we see
one of those two uh disclaimer obviously
people make fun of me for making
disclaimers but then they also get
really upset
if you don't disclose things so make
make up your mind do you want
disclosures or not
do you care about ethics or not i'm
gonna keep disclosing
um i do work for sony we're watching a
sony stream and i work for sony no idea
what's
in it my reactions will be genuine but i
would like to give you that disclosure
anyway
that i am an employee of playstation
studios
and my family of video game makers will
probably be showcased in
this stream also yes hyperdragon the way
i say assume
is like there's an sh how do you say
tissue
sir all right riddle me that how do you
say tissue
is it tissue anyway
i think i maybe need to turn probably
desktop down a little bit
uh only on youtube for this one i mostly
do do a lot of streams on twitch and i'm
planning to partner on twitch so i would
go over there
that's probably gonna happen pretty soon
uh but for stuff like this because it's
like
seems like youtube content to watch like
a reaction or conference afterwards i'll
probably still
do a lot of these on youtube rather than
on twitch but go there anyway
okay let's hit play shall we tell me if
there are any audio issues
uh again i have not had any of the
spoiled don't know what i'm in for
excited about it
you did play right it's loud
there's some very unexpected
developments in your future
shocking events that could change the
course crash bandicand
that last part might have been a hair
dramatic but there's lots i love crash
bandicoot
that includes crashful it's really good
adaptive triggers
i was surprised by how much i enjoyed it
let's make this fun
picking up where crash bandicoot works
seems like a weird opening crash no
choice for something
we find the evil masterminds neocortex
and dr
entropy escaping uh so adrian asked
is this on twitch leaving giant poles in
the universe
i'm not sure what entirely your question
means but it is marsupial
i'm not streaming on touch right now we
designed crash bandicoot 4 to leap off
your screen
brimming with bold vibrant environments
and characters
crash bandicoot has always looked pretty
suave but wait until you see him
spinning heads in native 4k
devastatingly i did play this game on
xbox with the weight of the universe on
your shoulder and thus
will probably not pick it up one place
on loading screens
the dual sense wireless controllers
bring adaptive triggers to your
fingertips
so you can feel the blast of music i do
really like the genes
i'm a big fan of the jewel sense or feel
the grip when you grapple at his hook
hold on tight when you feel the boost of
crash's jet board
and really feel the suck when you vacuum
his dingo really
feel the sound
achieving the infamous 106 completion is
the sign of
flashback levels and boss fights
i bet entropy wishes he had that even
bring your incomplete
i recently from the playstation 4 did
use the activity cards to get
106 entirety of road to nowhere one more
thing
if you own the ps4 version uh in one
sitting without dying even once
which is crash one for full details i
think most people would agree
through no it's not to know why that i
mean i did do road to november with the
one that's after that what's up
it's about to know it and a level
immediately off with
i did it in one sitting without dying
and i am notoriously bad at crash
maybe i've improved welcome back crash
the gang's all here on today's new
edition of state of play
we've got some great updates lined up
for you
first let's check out the latest on an
eagerly anticipated game coming to the
ps5 console this spring
from playstation studios is this for
title hey everyone
we at house mark are excited to give you
this sneak peek
at eternal that's what i thought in
return you will play as celine
an astra scout who crash lands on an
alien it looks so good
it looks so good receiving a mysterious
signal
white shadow players will explore this
inscrutable
dark planet i'm super into it unfold
mysteries
which may point to a larger force at
play
it's uh dark souls uh universe crossover
that's the thing nobody expected enemies
is key to survival in return
it actually looks a little bit more like
control than i would have thought
i mean or maybe it's just that the
camera is reminding me of that
obviously dead space vibes
definitely gears of war vibes um but
also just that
that dash looked a bit more like control
with the larger and yeah the camera
and the vast number of unique movesets
each possess
combat situations prove challenging no
matter what the circumstances uh
supplement gosh why am i looking
weird um it's probably the eyeliner
i started doing my eyeliner properly
and um every time you
people think you start the world will
change oh map will be different
it's procedures will appear in new
locations and in different i did my
eyeliner differently and people like did
you get plastic surgery what happened
no i just learned how to do eyeliner
properly it turns out i was doing it
real bad
it was like making me look more tired
this is
so it's procedurally generated then is
what you're telling me
i'm not sure you will stumble across
mysterious devices that can grant
rewards to the player
these will vary from weapons consumables
and upgrades and they can completely
change your playstyle
and make a cycle feel unique ah
i don't like any of that besides the
intense combat
return also has a deep and engaging
narrative
we allow i wonder if the fabricator
works
dead space three at all
that weapon customization was actually
really good in that game that's
oh my house that can't be here
i think i am reliving my memories in
that house but
not fully they're corroded
some parts are missing others seem
manufactured vanquish
on xbox 360. i don't know about that
i guess i can see that in the ui a bit i
love vanquish
love vanquish it's so good
the rocket mechanics ah
what a game
exactly as i left it i'm into it
i'm into it
cool yes good
return lands on april 30th and it's
developed by the talented team at house
mark
thank you for asking what i have for
dinner charles i've not eaten yet i just
finished work at a high impact
new ps4 game called knockout city
i don't think i know about this
hi i'm josh from bellin studios we're an
indie developer based in upstate new
york and we recently announced knockout
city
a team-based multiplayer action game for
ps4 where rival crews settle their
scores with epic dodgeball battles
kind of looks like um the ninja theory
games to pick up and play but there's a
lot of depth here for those who've got
the skills
just in the style 1v1 faceoff i don't
know what that was ahead in a constantly
shrinking battleground relying on your
reflexes and abilities
what was it i can picture the box out
but i don't remember the name time catch
powers up the ball making it easier to
land a hit
cool use trick shots to lob a ball over
a ledge or hook it around a corner
a last-second dodge is the difference
between getting knocked out and staying
in the fight
keep your wits about you as uh i
uninstalled it
there's a game that i played on my
channel not too long ago that looks a
little bit like this as well that was
actually really fun
um i ended up playing it fun house as
well teamwork makes the dream work they
all really like can be really fun but
not necessarily the kind of game that i
think i will play
we're playing a back alley brawl a new
map that you'll find in our upcoming
cross play beta
the special ball for this match is the
sniper ball which locks onto targets
from far across the map and
wham so that is a football before they
have a chance to react beyond special
balls
each map features a unique mechanic in
back alley brawl you can hop into a tube
and make a quick getaway or use them to
sneak up on your opponents
caught empty-handed you can literally
become the ball
a new weapon that's cute
hey i like the style charge up a
teammate every time that i see a game
that looks like this i just want more
jet set radio
explosion free time
[Music]
the team here at velen has been obsessed
with building this world over the last
four years
knockout city is coming first and we'd
love your help in our final stretch of
development
rally your crew and sign up for our
crosstalk
to play early on see you soon brawlers
uh no nick i didn't watch the whole
direct i don't have time
i don't know what people have time i
feel like i can make time for this one
but uh 50 minute direct i just picked
bits and pieces
time for something new here's your first
look at an upcoming ps5 game from the
team at slow clap
i like that they've done this this way
instead of like the creepy cg they had
for the last one that i remember
[Music]
i feel like i'm already into whatever
this is
i like this style a lot it's old boy
there's no way this isn't inspired by
old boy
the whole way fighting that movie is
incredible
yeah come on now
oh [ __ ] it got hot it's all it takes
facial hair
make anyone hot
this is cool it looks like it's got that
like
arkham style combat sleeping dogs
mordor
yes yes we like it yes good yes
yes that was the debut
big fan coming to the ps5 console later
this year
cool as hell now let's get an update on
solar ash
an epic new ps5 adventure machine
this is uh not been very aaa at all so
far which
i'm cool with really do hope we see
deathly
though that is my number one most
anticipated game
of the year
[Music]
and just to be clear i've been saying
that since before i worked at sony i've
been saying that
since back when everyone called me an
xbox show
definitely it's real i'm alex preston
creative director of heart machine
you might know us as the team behind
hyper light drifter today so
we're going to show you the first peak
of gameplay for our new title
solar ash
solar ash is a huge stylish 3d
platformer focused on speed
movement and fluid looks sort of like if
you put hyper light drifter in a
different
known as the ultravoid which has been
consuming everything in a different
perspective
you play as ray a daring void runner who
has decided to venture
into this terrifying ray skywalker a
last-ditch effort to save her home world
rey is extremely agile able to speed
across the world with abilities akin to
skating
on the ash and clouds she can quickly
cover great distances well maybe this is
the
uh the year that we get all these games
that are just like sunset overdrive
movement and ray has everything for some
reason and something that really paved
the way
forever ago
oh yeah i get that uh m show jack game
looks like uh
johnny or apocalypse yeah this is some
awesome wintery ass [ __ ]
you'll find yourself face to face with
grotesque and violent creatures
our combat system is simple fast and
fluid
filled to empower players and encourage
flow
as you explore the ultravoid enemy
encounters will scale to greater and
greater sizes
some of these creatures require speed
and precise timing to defeat
ray will eventually need to face the
massive cell very pretty
wretched starved beasts that hold the
key to her quest well that's very abzu
too
oh definitely vastly more likely i'm not
trying to say it's an open world game
it's just making a feel of moving play
on the grinding on everything
and the high stakes battles i don't
think this game would be anything like
sunset overdrive in reality being
players something
have i seen this i feel like i might
have more importantly fun
this game is a labor of love for
everyone on the heart machine team
we're excited to bring solar ash to ps5
and ps4
later this year cool
i'm sure that game will be fantastic for
the record like for anyone who's even
not interested in that game
i would bet money that game ends up
getting nines intense
it will be good you were nothing
you were small pathetic
am i doing it no you want more
i feel like i'm doing it did i do it did
it look good
[Music]
oh i was gonna guess that this was
freddy's okay
but then there's like a maze of some
kind
[Music]
what is this gregory we can get you out
of here
you and me together
[Music]
i mean it could just be standard five
nights at freddy's but i feel like every
no
so you can walk around they won't stop
hunting you none of them will stop
hunting you
ooh yes
we have to get you out by morning
so it's five nights at freddy's but
you're not just stuck behind a desk
your music is really good right you will
bring me
what i want and if you fail me
then you will both of you
a very interesting evolution of the
series
[Music]
again i've not played every five nights
at freddy's game by any stretch so i
could be completely wrong i could have
done stuff like this and i wouldn't know
[Music]
into it i will play almost anything
horror though so
[Music]
there is more going on here than you
[Music]
realize
cool is it just called security breach
uh five nights at parties security
breaches that was a chilling new look at
five nights at freddy's security breach
cool up next let's take a tour of
oddworld
first person stealth survival finance
parties game yeah that checks out
yeah hi i'm lauren lanning creative
director at odd world inhabitants
today i'm going to take you on a brief
tour of our newest the alien survival
horror game a model
is uh alien isolation
do you know an agreement in soul storm
you reprise the role of i don't have a
tremendous amount of interest in odd
world
but i will say as you do battle through
i did like these games a lot when i was
a lot younger
the fact that this franchise is still
going is worth the study
of it's uh like it we really wanted to
wow this world to life with what we call
been around for a long time performing
which adds much more
haptic feedback as you'll now be able to
feel abe's heartbeat in high alert and
suspenseful situations
oh cool there are well over one thousand
fellow mudakins that you must try to see
i am excited to see what a lot of
different studios end up doing without
helping with
workers looking to be safe what you can
do with the have to feedback what you
can do with them you'll be able to solve
puzzles harness their combined
microphone and be given the tools i love
the way some games use it
for uh the the light and there will be
times when the exterior
will be needed as you face off against
an array of heavily armed enemies that
will stop at nothing to find
an end abe once and for all games are
really fun
but i think that i don't in order to
play too many i think
the aesthetic is a much larger threat
i'm just not as interested ability to
scavenge and pickpocket items from his
surroundings and use them to craft an
impressive arsenal of his own thing
oh they've had remakes which i would
count you can also play as a non-lethal
pacifist or an agent of chaos
we wanted you to have a choice cpr but
there is one iconic ability for our
shamanic prototype
sam i'm just going to answer this while
we're looking at that
when can we expect next dj stream with
this music
i did i haven't done any dj streams
anymore because i kind of
still hit lost the appeal when people
started being drugged because it was
like supposed to give people good
vibes and then people started being
shitty and i was like situations that
require the minute everyone in the chat
engages with the shitty bus and it kind
of like defeats why i was trying to do
it
um but i did do one that was a mixture
of ancient
full guys and uh
um but it was fun it won't be easy if
being hunted by an
army backed by a shady and wealthy or a
lot of video game music out there that
uh of natural obstacles
ancient traps trials against swarming
dark creatures
and industrialization it's way too
underwhelming to get that much screen
time and avoid
sly i don't inherently disagree but
freedom and truth there's an engaging
just based on what's happening so far
this state of play is supposed to be
like and i think that life like never
before
i feel like people keep having their
expectations off with some of these
things in-game
will decide the fate of abe and all
those i feel like and this is just my
perspective i have absolutely no idea
it's more of a direct approach why this
one seems to be more about double a or
indie
um and it's just a place to show off
games that you know
don't get marketed why are you looking
at my soul
that don't necessarily get marketed in
the same way but i don't think that we
should expect every single
one of these to be like an e3 conference
here's some exciting news
active playstations some of the
predictions i sold version for no extra
cost
starting in april people are just like
why do you think this is going to be
that it's so
i did it moving on people expecting
things that i feel like i don't expect
at all okay this game i'm excited about
aaa technically but i i just don't think
it's
that kind of showcase is what i'm saying
i mean
aaa i mean you know the highly budgeted
highly marketed because the term doesn't
really mean [ __ ] anymore
this game looked really cool when we
first saw it very cute
studio ghibli vibes
[Music]
the rocks are quite fond of me they're
usually timid
something tells me you did not come to
our village
looking for forest creatures this is so
cute
hello spirit i seek passage to the
sacred mountain shrine
be cute be cute be cute our village is
bound to the shrine's energy
but that power oh it's free on ps plus i
didn't catch that oh that's that's great
i don't have to buy it there you go
i kind of do want you to support the
studio it's conflict
yeah downloads help
[Music]
trapped spirits linger here
tangled in the tragedy this is gorgeous
[Music]
it's okay it looks so pixel in
cut scenes and i feel like that's
confusing my brain a bit oh okay
big boy bosses also is there no ui or is
that just what we're seeing
i mean hud we're not seeing
any display
[Music]
into it
you must move on
that's so ghibli not that they have the
ownership of that or anything oh yeah
jess i could see this being zelda like
for sure wow damn okay
all right oh that animation was good
that was so wow
[Music]
damn that was freaky okay very oh that's
my birthday
it comes out on my birthday now let's
settle in for a stylish show
yes please loop playable pixar
team at our team she said it
she said the thing what you'll never
ever break this
loop there's no never here just you i
want this game so bad
bring it baby
this is rambling frank's matinee
this little ditty goes out to the
handsome [ __ ]
trying to break our loop cold the
visionaries are ready to dance
are you i know that you're in a loop the
the suggestion that someone would know
that you're trying to break the loop is
an interesting
addition to the lore of this world
[Music]
i love arcane i love arcane
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
when can i get this song though
[Music]
very dishonored the sonic 2 is one of my
favorite games
um it's so good
this is so stylish it's like bond
i just think the concept of this game
absolutely rules like
dishonored mixed with hitman all on
like a uh groundhog day kind of loop
[Music]
and it also seems like a wall that has
like really interesting and different
and unique tech
so james bondi
[Music]
oh my god i love it
i wonder how hitman it'll be
i mean in in dishonored you always could
do hitman kills like dishonored 2 does
have a lot of like mess with this thing
and get this person to mess with this
thing so they like kind of kill
themselves type stuff
song's over people and so is rambling
frank
the rest of you [ __ ] are next
i have chills
[Music]
ah i don't understand why everyone is
sleeping on death loop
okay that's what gets me that game looks
cool as [ __ ]
how about it's so [ __ ] one of the
cool 20s most
celebrating feel like i'm the only one
being like death loop
hey we're just going come on
help me
why would they have announced gta 6 in
february
why why would they have done that uh
trap in new york
probably wouldn't have gone into this
expecting gta 6.
a touching reunion
well guys your girl finally made it to
midgar
is this part two i feel like it doesn't
i just assumed that it wasn't
based on the way it looked material
hunter and elite special forces
operative for the new wutai government
will prove to our common enemy that
wutai is not to be trifled with
members of avalanche dlcs yes i'm back
someone's been expecting you what took
you sorry about that
anyway it's nice to meet you i'm sonan
kasakuben you're hot where's clown
we lost him you what he will be okay
though
what right well of course he will oh
it's dlc
that makes sense for whatever reason it
wasn't presented in a way that seemed to
me like it was part two
which i don't know what they're calling
it after what they've done you've gotta
assume shinra's on their tail
look a moogle hmm
[Laughter]
if i ever want someone to turn around
i'm gonna be like look oh moogle just
see what happens
it's ps5 exclusive dlc oh well the game
was playstation exclusive wasn't it
obviously it was ps4 but
[Music]
interesting
no freaking way
you guys should probably get moving
whatever it is they're planning
you're better off out of this they
deserve what's coming
yeah they do but i'm not your sister
she is cute though there you are who are
these jerks
no clue it just appeared
integrate of course it's called that now
let the hunch begin
is that me
get down here
they're bringing graphics to the
playstation 5.
[Music]
like
i mean that lighting looks better
it's kind of cool for a studio to do
this i mean obviously it's the marketing
team but
uh instead of like digital foundry doing
every single one of them
[Music]
textures on ps5 you got textures on that
thing
damn oh wow that looks way better
[Music]
it's like the draw distance is
more impressive
man just clearer when it's further away
i feel like it's uh the lighting is
better
the textures are visible from further
away
and they've made changes to the fog
quality of life of the ps5
oh it's an upgrade cool
[Music]
that was pretty boss
very good
i feel like i faked that all the time
very pretty
wait what
someone how far away the second part is
going to be though
you see that that's how ninjas do it
yep
[Music]
cool but you have to pay the
the dlc that makes sense
cool cool with it
um don't know that i'll play it uh but
i'm cool
reveal a final fantasy vii remake
integrate
coming to the ps5 console later this
year
and that's our show but that's it you're
as excited as we are i mean that went by
pretty quickly
did go by really fast see you next time
i thought it was real snappy
i don't know why this still looks like
there's so much time left it's probably
just that
um yeah they got through everything
really fast i liked that it was just vo
instead of having their cuts to
to people all the time which looked a
little bit disjointed to me last time i
continued to be like
so freaking hyped about death loop my
gosh i can't wait uh cooney is that what
it's called
also looks awesome like very very into
that obviously um
yeah cool show did not expect it to be
the triple a ship i think
show i think a lot of other people seem
to have expected for some reason
um maybe we need to i don't know
just like not expect them to be that
unless they say that is kind of my
takeaway from it
uh but maybe that's just a perception
that i got through working in the
industry for so long rather than
something that is like
the general public's fault i don't know
um definitely how i feel about it though
uh all right that is it for me tonight
everyone
i'm gonna clean my apartment and make
some dinner i am gonna stream tomorrow
uh not sure what time but i'm gonna try
and hit
80 085 gamer score specifically so i can
get boobs gamer score
um could take a while but it's pretty
important clearly
pretty important stuff so i'm gonna do
that tomorrow night it should be a good
time